have you heard that there is a student
loan crisis looming I'm sure if you have
have you heard that there's about 1.4
trillion dollars now outstanding and
student loan debt most people can't
count to a trillion you don't have time
you actually have something else to do
right have you heard that there's a
number of young people that their entire
lives have been destroyed supposedly by
these horrible student loans that are
writing them into the dirt
they're delaying their careers that are
laying the start of their families
they're living in their parents homes
all because of the student loan burden
that they carry student loans are
ruining people's lives I'm not sure I
completely agree with all of that
because I talk to people all the time
who have paid off their student loans
and paid an incredible price some of
them a lot of hard work over a number of
years and extra jobs and denying
themselves and selling stuff and paying
off their 50 or 60 or 160 thousand
dollars or two hundred and sixty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
they call here every week doing their
debt free screams you hear them right
now let's just for a second stop this I
just had a thought student loans are out
of control
student loans are destroying an entire
generation of kids that's what a lot of
people really really believe I don't
completely believe it but I believe that
to a degree I think it's a horrible mess
would you you got all say it's a
horrible mess and you can blame the
idiot children for signing up for a
hundred thousand dollars in debt you can
blame their idiot parents for telling
them that's the only way to do it the
idiot culture for telling them that no
matter what you pay for an education
it's worth it you can blame the colleges
and
Versa T's for charging too much for the
education cost of education has gone
through the roof now well as a supply
demand curve thing if you had an
education economics you'd understand
that if you have a tremendous amount of
dollars chasing something then guess
what they will raise the price on you
and so the student loans have
availability have pretty much caused
been one of the major causes of the
increase in education cost because
there's a lot of people going to college
no matter what the price hmm so the
student loans that you're aware I'm sure
you understand they are federally
insured meaning that no bank in its
right mind would make an
eighteen-year-old kid
$100,000 loan unsecured and hope he
graduated from college to pay be able to
pay it back in a degree field that
actually wasn't left-handed puppetry no
bank would ever make that loan the only
reason banks make that loan is is that
the government you and I the taxpayer is
guaranteeing the bank that they're not
going to lose money it's a federally
insured guaranteed loan and so the
bank's like we have zero chance of
losing money on this loan yeah we'll
make that line absolutely we'll make it
okay so let's kind of follow the
critical thinking of you and I the
idiots that we are in this culture and
the dumber crazier Congress people we
have elected here's the thing if society
and our government is May
available things to young people that
are destroying their lives shouldn't
somebody think about stopping I mean if
you were handing out cigarettes to kids
and then you discovered that it causes
lung cancer and you're killing this
generation of kids and the government
was paying for it shouldn't we tell the
government to stop killing our children
and participating in the ridiculous
process if student loans have caused
such a crisis and most people agree that
it's some more dramatically than other
that there's at least a crisis of some
degree here if student loans are such a
bad thing and I agree that they're a bad
thing and they're so out of control and
I agree that they're out of control and
they really are messing up people's
lives if that is the case we're doing
harm to our children by giving them
student loans simple critical thought
and logical process takes you to that
conclusion so why are we continuing to
do that it's driving up the cost of
college people are overwhelmed oh
there's a huge default billions and
billions of billions of dollars of
student loans in default meaning you and
I the taxpayer are going to pay them
because a little junior for whatever
reason didn't pay the bill and if he
doesn't pay the bill you and I pay the
bill and so we're not happy paying the
bill the kids aren't happy they got
their lives destroyed and yet no one is
discussing stopping this stupidity stop
the insanity that's just insane and
you're suggesting no more student loans
yeah I am I don't think it's going to
happen but I'm suggesting that it's
illogical too
a student loans are destroying people's
lives oh let's keep doing it it's
illogical it doesn't make sense well you
can't get through college without
student loan well how's that working for
you I have a dr. Phil moment with that
it's not working billions are in default
we've got little hipsters with their
growth growth all stunted because of
their student loan debt living in
mommy's basement and they got degrees
and crap that don't make any difference
because they ain't thinking about what
they were getting the degree in because
we told them a lie about education that
it doesn't matter what your degree is in
as long as you get a degree you're going
to be successful and that's just a bunch
of crap you got a PhD in German polka
history that's just straight-up stupid
then just walk around whining because
you can't get a job well no wonder
there's not a big demand for German
polka history use some dadgum sense
parents ain't got sense enough to stop
it
kids haven't got sense enough to stop
but the banks aren't going to stop
loaning the money they're getting a
guarantee from Congress you're going to
sit on the sidelines and do nothing and
you can count on Congress doing nothing
it's what they do best but we're doing
harm to our kids and no one's suggesting
we stop it something to think about I
don't think it'll happen but it
shouldn't be stopped
shouldn't it this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
down
[Applause]
[Music]